[Music]
all right our big story tonight the
former interim DNC chair Donna Brazile
is now saying that she has the smoking
gun evidence that Hillary Clinton rigged
the DNC in order to keep Socialist from
Vermont Bernie Sanders from winning the
Democratic primary Donna Brazile is
making the revelations in her new book
which will be out next week this is
massive now keep in mind this is
something President Trump he's been
saying for months you may remember this
the DNC Democratic National Committee
rigged the Democratic election the
primary process to take it away from
Bernie and give it to Hillary Clinton
the DNC vice-chair was caught feeding
information about Bernie Sanders plans
to the Clinton campaign you're not
supposed to do that well president Trump
was right again Donna Brazile in her
upcoming book she describes how she was
tasked with investigating the Democratic
National Committee after hacked emails
suggested yes the Clinton campaign was
colluding with the DNC it's even worse
than that
now one excerpt from the book Brazil
slams her predecessor debbie Wasserman
Schultz writing quote that he was not a
good manager she hadn't been very
interested in controlling the party that
she let Intan headquarters in Brooklyn
do as its so desired she didn't have to
inform the party officers how bad the
situation was how much control Brooklyn
had and for how long was still something
I had been trying to uncover for the
last few weeks by September the 7th the
day I called Bernie I had found my proof
and it broke my heart
wow that's powerful and this shows just
how low the Clintons will go to get what
they want even senator Elizabeth Warren
is now admitting that the DNC primary
process was in fact rigged watch this
this is a real problem but what we've
got to do is Democrats nailed is we've
got to hold this party accountable this
is a test for Tom Perez
and either he's going to succeed by
bringing Bernie Sanders and Bernie
Sanders representatives into this
process and they're going to say it's
fair it works we all believe it or he's
going to fail and I very much hope he
succeeds I hope for Democrats everywhere
I hope for Bernie and for all Bernie
supporters there's going to succeed very
quickly senator do you agree with the
notion that it was rigged yes
rigged and stolen election primary
earlier today Wasserman Schultz gave a
statement to the Fox News Channel that
completely avoided the topic at hand it
reads this in part with Donald Trump in
the White House Democrats must stay
focused on enacting a progressive agenda
to protect our citizens our values and
our democracy and remain united towards
our goal of electing Democratic
congressional majorities in 2018 okay
that's not a denial of anything but it's
a clear example of just what senator
Bernie Sanders was up against in the
2016 Democratic primary I had said it
many times now just moments ago the
president Donald Trump he tweeted Donna
Brazile just stated the DNC rigged the
system to illegally steal the primary
from Bernie Sanders bought and paid for
by crooked Hillary this is real
collusion and dishonesty major violation
of campaign finance laws and money
laundering where is our Justice
Department great questions
now this Clinton crime family because
that's what they really are and their
political machine was willing to put all
ethics aside do nothing anything
everything they could do to mow down the
one man anybody that stood in their way
now stop and think about this for a
minute could you just imagine if today
it was a revealed president Trump if he
was accused and there was evidence that
he rigged the RNC in the primary in his
favor to help him and steal an election
could you imagine the outrage from the
all left
mainstream media there would be calls
for investigations into this all day but
today because this is a bad story for
Democrats your media which is so corrupt
they're barely covering
this is a breathtaking moment Hillary
Clinton she's the former Secretary of
State former first lady of our country
the former senator former first lady of
Arkansas rigged and stole a primary
election just look at Clinton right
there at the Democratic National
Convention
she stole those moments think about that
for a minute what is the most basic
things you teach your children in life
let's say you need to be fair honest
trustworthy you shouldn't lie you
shouldn't cheat and you shouldn't steal
when it comes to Hillary Clinton she
didn't embody one of those principles
and it proves nothing was gonna stop
Hillary Clinton's blind ambition now
when it comes to emails after they were
subpoenaed if we had subpoenaed emails
we'd have to turn them over she didn't
want you to see them what did she do oh
she deleted them acid-washed them she
she used bleach pits smashed devices
with hammers when it comes to Hillary
Clinton there is ZERO stopping this
woman no law no subpoena no warrant no
ethics guide this woman's life this is
by far the worst thing and I've covered
the Clintons for years they have ever
done Hillary Clinton accuses President
Trump of collusion and she stole bought
and paid for the fake anti Trump dossier
and it doesn't matter in the process she
sold our security out in this country
uranium one we're talking about the most
unethical person I have ever seen in my
entire life
and by the way Bernie Sanders you never
stood a shot and speaking to you Bernie
you should be ashamed of yourself you
knew you knew you were told there's
evidence that that primary was stolen
and you ended up supporting her anyway
you said nothing this woman had zero
ethics Bernie Sanders would have
literally elected a person and he
covered for a person who stole hit the
election with him he apparently was okay
with that
I don't know what's wrong with you
Bernie and for all of you that voted
tonight for Hillary Clinton this is the
person that you wanted to be your
president this disgrace will follow her
the rest of
life also tonight while Hillary Clinton
was apparently running the DNC she was
in charge of it she was also using their
funds to pay a former foreign spy to
make up those salacious untrue
accusations in the dossier about
President Trump then candidate Trump now
Hillary Clinton has broken her silence
on the dossier finally the one she
helped fund that she was running through
a law firm here's what she told The
Daily Show's Trevor Noah last night is
there a difference between your team
paying for this opposition research and
Donald Trump's people working with the
Russians to influence the election is
there a difference of course there is
and you know I think most serious people
understand that this was research
started by a Republican donor during the
Republican primary and then when Trump
got the nomination for the Republican
Party the people doing it came to my
campaign lawyer and said you know would
you like us to continue it and and he
said yes he's an experienced lawyer he
knows what the law is he knows what
opposition research is did you just you
just hear her what you have there what
she's admitting to is real actual
Russian propaganda lies that she bought
and paid for the Clinton political
machine and the Democratic Party the DNC
she's running that they funded through a
third party source in what was a
shameless attempt to steal the election
by lying to you the American people the
president was asked by our own Laura
Ingraham earlier today about this very
thing watch this that dossier which is
totally fake
and made-up it's like a novel but that
dossier is a disgrace and it should not
have been allowed to be used and then I
hear the kind of money they spent nine
million I mean it's inconceivable
it's absolutely inconceivable it's
horrible so we don't know who authorized
payment we don't really well they're
trying to find out and we'll find out
but they really I think it's a disgrace
that a thing like that can take place
beyond a disgrace that was all designed
to manipulate the American people the
president's write crooked Hillary
Clinton was caught in the act
using a foreign source to influence the
election steal the election again if you
need any more evidence that Hillary
Clinton was willing to do anything and
everything to win the 2016 election you
need to look no further than that
dossier now remember those full lies
propaganda salacious details
she lost miserably in the election and
now America is really truly getting to
know the dark ruthless side of Hillary
Clinton now we're gonna get back to that
in just a few minutes but first we have
another story almost too shocking to
believe Twitter's lawyer admitted
earlier today this week to lawmakers
that the social media giant you know
Twitter we all use Twitter that they
literally hid tweets and hashtags that
were connected to the DNC and John
Podesta Z mails now in his prepared
testimony before the Senate Subcommittee
on crime and terrorism
Twitter's acting general counsel
acknowledged Twitter hit over 60,000
tweets with the hashtag DNC leak and hit
another hundred and six thousand tweets
with the hashtag Podesta emails now
could this be a serious violation of
federal law we'll have an investigation
in a minute either way it is clear
evidence that Twitter was holding water
for the Clinton campaign and Democrats
have the gall to complain about fake
news on Facebook the hypocrisy is
breathtaking we'll follow that story and
also tonight for months we have been
exposing the most dangerous Clinton
scandal of all that's the Iranian one
scandal
tonight we have even more new damning
information to bring you the hills John
Solomon Allison span they are out
tonight with another absolutely stunning
report the headline is this uranium one
deal led to some exports to Europe this
has been the number one excuse they've
been they've been telling us John
Solomon is reporting tonight that after
the Obama administration approved the
sale of uranium 1 now we're
remember 2009 we know knew about lies
and bribes and kickbacks and extortion
money laundering and racketeering and
they still allow the deal through but
anyway the Nuclear Regulatory Commission
gave assurances the raw nuclear fuel
would never be export exported out of
this country but Solomon he obtained the
NRC memos they did approve the shipment
of yellowcake uranium from the u.s. to
Canada through a third-party trucking
company and unbelievably some of that
nuclear material made its way all the
way to Europe maybe even Asia John
Solomon writes quote uranium one exports
flowed from Wyoming to Canada on to
Europe between 2012 and 2014 and the
approval involved a process with
multiple agencies now the American
branch of uranium one gave a statement
to the hill confirming it did export
uranium to Canada through the trucking
firm and that 25% of that nuclear fuel
made its way outside of North America to
Europe and Asia Wow
this has been their number one excuse
they stress the exports complied with
federal law yeah because they used the
company and then they didn't have to get
their own license and a statement from
the Nuclear Regulatory Commission reads
in part the NRC licensing actions
complied with the Atomic Energy Act
section 123 agreement where the
receiving country in this case Canada is
required to commit to use the material
for only peaceful purposes by the way
does anyone at home know we import
uranium because we don't have enough so
when the Iranian made its way to Canada
to Europe what then how did that happen
now if this material is crossing the
Atlantic what is preventing it from
getting into Russia and the question
remains why in the hell would anybody
approve the sale of 20% of America's
uranium to Vladimir Putin and the bad
actor he is and the hostile regime
Russia government approved by Hillary
Clinton Eric Holder other high-ranking
officials in the Obama administration
John Solomon Sarah Carter they will join
us they will give us a full
investigative report